I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who are there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Pack your bags, lady. Are we going to Tallahassee?
我是詹妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们专门为你带来了终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室娇娃。收拾好行囊，女士。我们要去塔拉哈西吗？
We are Sam Cassie Angela Me, special project. It's happening. Yeah, it's not really going to be a Tallahassee. No, but it's fun idea. Some people are in today's episode. I have wanted for a long time to do an office lady's road trip. This is true, you have. I'm gonna make it happen.
我们是萨姆、卡西、安吉拉、我，特别项目。要开始了。是的，其实不会去塔拉哈西。不，但这是个有趣的想法。今天节目中的一些人，我一直很想搞一次办公室娇娃的公路旅行。真的，你想过。我要把它变成现实。
Well, today, it's not happening, but today we are talking about special project which was season eight, episode 14, written by Amaligh Gillette and directed by Dave Rogers. Here's your summary. Angela's competitive mommy street continues as she and Pam returned from their respective maternity leaves.
好吧，今天，它并没有发生，但今天我们要讨论的是特别项目，也就是第八季第十四集，由阿马利·吉列编剧，戴夫·罗杰斯执导。这是剧情梗概：安吉拉好胜的辣妈气焰有增无减，她和帕姆各自结束产假回到了公司。
Dwight is excited to be heading a special project for Saber in Tallahassee, but not thrilled with the team Andy has appointed for him to lead. Meanwhile, Darryl tries to figure out the meaning behind his Valentine's Day gift from Val. Fast fact number one. Mm-hmm. This episode was a Valentine's Day episode. It was.
德怀特得知自己将领导世博公司在塔拉哈西的一个特别项目，感到兴奋不已，但对安迪为他指派的团队成员并不满意。与此同时，达里尔试图弄清楚瓦尔送他的情人节礼物背后的含义。第一条趣味冷知识。嗯哼。这一集是情人节特辑。确实是。
It aired on February 9th, 2012. Angela, no pressure, but will we be getting a Valentine's Day to core breakdown from you later? No. Oh no! I didn't do it because I was like, Angela's probably gonna break down all these baskets and cupids. There's so many. I do have one background catch that I wonder if anyone
它于2012年2月9日播出。安吉拉，没有压力，不过稍后我们会从你那儿听到关于情人节装饰的剖析吗？没有。哦，不！我没做，因为我想，安吉拉可能会剖析所有这些篮子和小丘比特。实在太多了。我确实有一个背景彩蛋，不知道有没有人
else noticed, but I'm gonna wait. Okay. Well, I'll have you know that this episode was a hit with fans and critics, Miles McNutt, who we have not checked in on in a while. I've been wondering, he gave this episode, are you ready for it? No, an A minus. Come on! We have not been in the A's for a while. Miles McNut gave it an A minus.
注意到，但我先不说。好吧。嗯，我要告诉你的是，这一集深受粉丝和评论家的喜爱，迈尔斯·麦克纳特，我们好久没关注他了。我一直在想，他对这一集的评价是，你准备好了吗？没有，A减。拜托！我们好久没拿到A档的评价了。迈尔斯·麦克纳特给它打了个A减。
Yes. He did say this, he always prefaces his good news even. Okay, he said, quote, I could take some time to question how exactly this Grant and Branch is going to operate without six people for three weeks. And I could also ask about the economics of a printer company establishing an Apple-esque retail
是的。他确实这么说了，他甚至总是先给好消息做个铺垫。好吧，他说，原话是，“我可以花点时间质疑这个格兰特分支机构在没有六个人的情况下如何运作整整三周。我还可以质疑一家打印机公司建立苹果风格的零售
presence. That was one for me too, Miles. Like the majority of Saber's storylines since the company's introduction, there. Like the majority of Saber's storylines since the company's introduction, there's a fundamental lack of logic operating here that does puzzle the part of me that enjoys policing the show's reality.
店的经济学逻辑。”这也是我想问的，迈尔斯。就像世博公司自引入以来的大多数故事线一样，这里
But he loved the potential of the storyline. He talked about how great it has been in the past when characters branched off to different locations. Like he said, it was so successful when Jim went to Stanford or when Pam Ryan and Michael made Michael Scott paper company. He also loved the people who were ultimately chosen to go on the trip. I honestly have not seen Miles this excited in a while. I think I have to take off my earrings.
存在着一种根本性的逻辑缺失，这确实让那些喜欢纠结于剧集现实逻辑的观众感到困惑。但他非常喜欢这条故事线的发展潜力。他谈到过去当角色分流到不同地点时效果有多好。就像他说的那样，当吉姆去斯坦福，或者当帕姆、瑞安和迈克尔创立迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司时，都非常成功。他也非常喜欢最终被选中去旅行的人。说实话，我好久没看到迈尔斯这么兴奋了。我觉得我得把耳环摘了。
Oh, why? Well, they're made- Are they jingling? They're jingling. Look at, I took them fromingling. They're jingling. They're, look at, I took them from my daughter. They're little zippers. They're so cute. I know. I was trying to be stylish, but then I was like, oh no, am I just a mom trying to hard with her daughter's trendy zipper earrings that are now rattling in my ear. I thought they looked cute. Thank you. I was curious by them. They seemed like a branch out for you. I know. And I thought Jenna's wearing little zippers.
哦，为什么？嗯，它们是——它们在叮当响吗？它们在叮当响。看，我是从——叮当响。它们是，看，我是从我女儿那里拿来的。它们是小拉链。它们太可爱了。我知道。我本来想赶时髦，但后来我想，哦不，我是不是那种拼命想跟女儿戴时髦拉链耳环的妈妈，结果现在它在我耳边哗啦作响。我觉得它们看起来挺可爱的。谢谢。我对它们挺好奇的。感觉对你来说是个突破。我知道。我想詹妮弗戴着小拉链呢。
But you know what? You've told me you're trying to like step into a new kind of fashion. Like what is my fashion? Yeah. Anyway, I had to take the zippers off. So sorry everyone. Fast fact number two.
但你知道吗？你告诉过我你想尝试一种新的时尚风格。比如什么是我的时尚？对。总之，我得把拉链摘下来。非常抱歉，各位。第二条趣味冷知识。
And we're back. I thought the fact that Pam and Angela are both returning from maternity leave and the fact that we have been discussing my own maternity leave lately on the pod, I maybe it was time for a maternity leave deep dive, like a mini deep dive on maternity leaves. Sure.
我们回来啦。我觉得帕姆和安吉拉都要结束产假回归，加上我们最近在播客里一直在讨论我自己的产假，我觉得也许是时候深入探讨一下产假了，就像对产假进行一次小型深度探讨。当然。
Okay, I did not know what I was gonna find when I did the steep dive, but did you know that there are only eight countries in the world in the whole world that do not guarantee paid family leave at the national level for men and women? Did you know that eight? Do you want to know what they are? Well, I'm sure we're one of them. We are. We're one of the eight. They are Marshall Islands, of them. We are. We're one of the eight. They are Marshall Islands, Micronesia, Nauru, Palau, Papua New Guinea, Serenam, Tonga, and the United States. All of the other 187 countries in the world guarantee some kind of paid family leave. Wow. Yeah, here's what we have in the United States. In 1993, we passed the Family and Medical Leave Act.
好吧，我做这个深度探讨时并不知道自己会发现什么，但你知道全世界——整个世界上只有八个国家在国家层面不保证为男女提供带薪产假吗？你知道这八个国家吗？你想知道它们是哪些吗？好吧，我猜我们就是其中之一。我们是的。我们是其中八个之一。它们是马绍尔群岛、密克罗尼西亚、瑙鲁、帕劳、巴布亚新几内亚、苏里南、汤加和美国。世界上所有其他187个国家都保证某种形式的带薪家庭假。哇。是的，这就是我们在美国的现状。1993年，我们通过了《家庭与医疗假法》。
And that allows you to take up to 12 weeks of unpaid leave when you foster, adopt, or have a child, or in case of illness or a health condition whereby you can't work or if you need to care for an immediate family member. It just means you can't be fired. This is what I applied for when I had my son. I took leave from the office under this law. However, I'm saying that as if this is a major bright side, it's not, but sometimes paid leave is offered through your employer. But sometimes paid leave is offered through your employer. So definitely check that out.
它允许你在寄养、领养或生孩子时，或者在因病或健康状况无法工作、或者需要照顾直系亲属时，享有最多12周的无薪假。这只意味着你不会被解雇。这就是我生儿子时申请的。我根据这项法律向办公室请了假。不过，我这么说好像这是一个重大积极方面似的，其实并不是，但有时你的雇主会提供带薪假。但有时你的雇主会提供带薪假。所以一定要去了解一下。
And your state may offer some sort of disability or family leave paid. So there, I think there are like 11 states that do offer that. But on a national level, it is not guaranteed. Also under that family and medical leave act, I guess there are so many requirements in order to qualify that only about 60% of the workforce is actually eligible to take
而且你的州可能会提供某种带薪伤残假或家庭假。所以，我想大概有11个州确实提供这种假。但在国家层面，这是无法保证的。此外，根据《家庭与医疗假法》，我想有太多的资格要求，以至于只有大约60%的劳动力实际上有资格享受
the unpaid family leave. So loopholes, yeah. That was my very depressing maternity leave deep dive. I guess depressing if you live in the United States for all of our international listeners Congratulations. You have some sort of paid family leave. I always find it so fascinating. These kind of stats, you know? Yeah, you know when you grow up somewhere, you don't often question like why don't I have paid family leave? Why don't I have healthcare? Right. Why do I have to open up a go fund me if I'm in a car accident? It just becomes sort of like, well, this is what you do. Right. That's your reality. Yeah. And so
无薪家庭假。所以有很多漏洞，对吧。这就是我那令人沮丧的产假深度探讨。如果你住在美国的话，这确实挺令人沮丧的，致我们所有的国际听众，恭喜你们。你们享有某种带薪家庭假。我总是觉得这类统计数据非常迷人，你知道吗？对，你知道当你生长在某个地方时，你往往不会去质疑，为什么我没有带薪家庭假？为什么我没有医疗保健？对。如果我出了车祸，为什么我必须发起众筹？它只变成了一种“哦，这就是你该做的”事情。没错。这就是你的现实。对。所以
when you travel somewhere else and see that they don't have that burden and that stress, it's very eye opening. Yes. Or if you do a maternity leave deep dive and you sit at your computer in shock, and you're like, oh wow, it's like a kind of new this, but now I'm looking at it in black and white and it's, huh. Well, you know, Angela Martin only took a three-day maternity leave. That's right. Three days. That's all she needed. Dwight seemed upset about it. He did and when we get to that Angela I have a catch. Okay. Speaking of catches, are you ready for Fast Facts 3? I don't know if I can.
当你去其他地方旅游，看到他们没有那种负担和压力时，是非常大开眼界的。是的。或者如果你做了一次产假深度探讨，坐在电脑前感到震惊，你会想，哦，哇，我以前有点知道这个，但现在我看到白纸黑字写着，唉。好吧，你知道，安吉拉·马丁只休了三天产假。没错。三天。这就是她所需要的。德怀特对此似乎很不高兴。他确实很不高兴，当我们讲到那里时，安吉拉，我有个彩蛋。好的。说到彩蛋，你准备好迎接第三条趣味冷知识了吗？我不知道我能不能行。
This is a Florida fan catch fact check from Aaron W in New Mexico. Say that again. A Florida fan catch fact check. Yes. Oh, yeah, yeah. Fan catch fact check. Okay. Here is what Aaron had to say. I am a native Floridian. I grew up in Miami until I was 18, then moved to Tallahassee to attend Florida State University, and ended up living there for 11 years until I moved to New Mexico in late 2020. and ended up living there for 11 years until I moved to New Mexico in late 2020. I notice that all of Dunderclund thinks that all of Florida is the same, and they assume Tallahassee will be just like Miami, but let me tell you that you could not be more different. Tallahassee is a medium-sized quiet Southern College town. There are giant oak trees with Spanish moss and hardly any palm trees.
这是一个来自新墨西哥州的亚伦·W的关于佛罗里达粉丝穿帮的核实事实。再说一遍。佛罗里达粉丝穿帮事实核查。对。哦，对，对。粉丝穿帮事实核查。好的。亚伦是这样说的。我是土生土长的佛罗里达人。我在迈阿密长到18岁，然后搬到塔拉哈西去上佛罗里达州立大学，并在那里一直住到2020年底才搬到新墨西哥州。我注意到邓德米夫林的全体人员都认为整个佛罗里达都一样，他们以为塔拉哈西会和迈阿密一模一样，但请容我直言，你们的差距再大不过了。塔拉哈西是一个中等规模的宁静南方大学城。那里有挂着西班牙苔藓的巨大橡树，几乎没有棕榈树。
And while there aren't four distinct seasons, Tallahassee can get very cold in the winter months. So here are just a few things I noticed in special projects that made me think Dunder Mifflin assumes all of Florida is the same or that they will be actually in Miami. First, Dwight Tells Pam to pack swimwear. February and Tallahassee is not pool or beach weather. The closest beach to Tallahassee is almost 40 miles away. I guess the average temperature around Valentine's Day would be in the 60s. Next, Dwight mentions trips to Cape Canaveral. That is 309 miles away from Tallahassee. Oh dear.
虽然这里没有四季分明，但塔拉哈西的冬天会非常冷。所以以下是我在《特别项目》中注意到的一些事情，它们让我觉得邓德米夫林以为佛罗里达到处都一样，或者他们实际上会去迈阿密。首先，德怀特让帕姆打包泳衣。2月份的塔拉哈西可不是游泳或去海滩的天气。离塔拉哈西最近的海滩将近40英里远。我想情人节左右的平均气温应该在60华氏度左右。接下来，德怀特提到去卡纳维拉尔角的旅行。那离塔拉哈西有309英里远。天哪。
He mentions Gloria Estefan, who lives in Miami, which is 482 miles away. Then Dwight mentions it is 85 degrees Fahrenheit with a 73% immunity. Again, I understand he's trying to convince people not to go, but this weather is true for late spring summer, not February. Also, hurricane
他提到了住在迈阿密的格洛丽亚·埃斯特芬，那里距离482英里。然后德怀特提到气温是85华氏度，湿度73%。再次说明，我理解他是想说服大家不要去，但这种天气是春末夏初的真实写照，而不是2月份。此外，飓风
season does not officially begin until June 1st, and it runs to November 30th. Clearly, the writers did not consult anyone from Florida. No, as I was reading this letter, I was like, wow, wow, the people living in Tallahassee who are watching our episode right now just must be squirming. Although this is Dwight's perception of Florida, right? True. Yeah. Which may be tracks. Aaron did say that giant cockroaches,
季直到6月1日才正式开始，一直持续到11月30日。很显然，编剧们根本没有咨询任何佛罗里达人。不，当我读这封信的时候，我想，哇，哇，那些住在塔拉哈西、此刻正在看我们这一集的观众肯定在坐立不安。不过这是德怀特对佛罗里达的看法，对吧？没错。是的，这可能很符合他的性格。亚伦确实说过，巨大的蟑螂，
AKA Palmetto bugs do not Google this. Aaron said, are sadly accurate and they fly. I know they fly. I've had one fly at me. A cockroach. It's just maybe the most like undone I've ever come. Like you would have thought. I was like, I went crazy. Yeah, I don't like bugs that fly at me. Not big, hard shell crunchy ones either. That's right. I don't like that. I don't like. Finally, Aaron said mosquitoes and giant frogs are also accurate. Okay. Yeah. Okay. Well, Aaron, thank you very much for the telehassy breakdown. That's right. Well, now that we've set the record straight on maternity leave and Florida,
也就是帕尔梅托臭虫——千万别去谷歌搜这个。亚伦说，可悲的是这是真的，而且它们会飞。我知道它们会飞。曾有一只朝我飞过来。一只蟑螂。这可能是我遇到过的最让我崩溃的事了。你会以为我会发疯。是的，我不喜欢朝我飞过来的虫子。也不是那种又大又硬壳脆的虫子。没错。我不喜欢那样。我不喜欢。最后，亚伦说蚊子和大青蛙也是真的。好的。是的。好吧，亚伦，非常感谢你对塔拉哈西的剖析。没错。好了，既然我们已经澄清了关于产假和佛罗里达的事实，
well, maternity leave in Tallahassee, yes. There's Florida's big. We don't know all about Florida. Well, maternity leave in Dallas-Hassie. Yes, there's Florida's big. We don't know all about Florida. That was Aaron's point. Yes, I agree, Aaron. Let's take a break. And when we come back, it's Valentine's reception. It's very decorated for Valentine's. Sorry, I didn't do a cupid breakdown, but I have some other stuff. Pam was going to return. Everyone's very happy to see her. Stanley kind of hints that she's just had an eight-week vacation. Pam's like, um, was it really a vacation? Angela's also going to return after her three-day maternity leave, as we talked about. And this outfit was a whole meeting. I can tell you that. Really? Say more. They really wanted to sell this idea that she came back as if
好吧，是塔拉哈西的产假，是的。佛罗里达很大嘛。我们并不全了解佛罗里达。好吧，是塔拉哈西的产假。是的，佛罗里达很大嘛。我们并不全了解佛罗里达。这就是亚伦的观点。是的，我同意，亚伦。我们休息一下。当我们回来时，是情人节招待会。这里为情人节做了很多装饰。抱歉，我没有做丘比特剖析，但我还有其他一些东西。帕姆要回来了。每个人看到她都非常高兴。斯坦利有点暗示她只是度了一个八周的假期。帕姆则觉得，嗯，这真的是个假期吗？安吉拉在休完三天产假后也将回归，正如我们讨论过的那样。这套衣服可是开过好几次会议决定的。我可以告诉你。真的吗？展开说说。他们真的想贩卖这样一种理念：她回来时就好像
nothing had happened. I had multiple fittings. They wanted wanted to sell this idea that she came back as if nothing had happened. I had multiple fittings. They wanted everything to be tight fitted and very spelt. The belt was a whole conversation. Oh, I don't know if you notice, but I have a tight little turtle neck. And then I have the tiny skinny belt right at my waist. I did notice. And a pencil skirt.
什么都没发生过一样。我试穿了好多次。他们想让一切都紧身、非常苗条。腰带是个重点讨论对象。哦，我不知道你们有没有注意到，我穿着一件紧身的小高领毛衣。然后我腰间系着一条细细的窄皮带。我注意到了。还有一条铅笔裙。
Yeah. Everyone wanted the belt. I was like, do we really need And a pencil skirt. Yeah. Everyone wanted the belt. I was like, do we really need the belt? They're like, you need the belt. Because I guess the belt really accentuates the waist. You know what I thought when I saw the Angela from maternity leave and Pam from maternity leave? I thought Angela is Instagram and Pam is real life. That trend. Yes. Like, Angela is what postpartum moms on Instagram are showing you. They're snapback. Yeah.
对。每个人都想要这条腰带。我当时想，我们真的需要这条腰带吗？他们说，你需要这条腰带。因为我猜这条腰带真的很显腰细。你知道当我看到产假归来的安吉拉和产假归来的帕姆时，我想到了什么吗？我觉得安吉拉是Instagram风格，而帕姆是现实生活。那个潮流。是的。就好比，安吉拉是Instagram上的产后妈妈向你展示的样子。她们迅速恢复了身材。是的。
And then Pam is like at home being like, what the f? Is happening. Well, in addition to her outfit, she's also brought in a lot of snacks. Brownies and cookie bars. Brownies with and without walnuts. Yeah, because she does not have mommy brain. Yeah, she does know what Pam's talking about. Angela, I remember filming this moment
然后帕姆就像是在家里崩溃地说，这到底是怎么回事？好吧，除了她的衣服，她还带了很多零食。布朗尼和曲奇条。带核桃和不带核桃的布朗尼。对，因为她没有妈妈脑。是的，她确实知道帕姆在说什么。安吉拉，我记得在拍摄这个场景时，
where you offer me a brownie, and I have to decide if I'm gonna take it. And it kept making us laugh so hard. Not only did it make us laugh, but then after you take a bite, and you like the brownie, I know. Then you're like, what about you, don't you want one? only did it make us laugh, but then after you take a bite and you like the brownie. I know. Then you're like, what about you, don't you want one?
你递给我一块布朗尼，我得决定要不要接过来。这让我们笑得前仰后合。不仅让我们笑个不停，而且在你咬了一口、觉得布朗尼很好吃之后，我知道。然后你说，你呢，你不想要一块吗？不仅让我们笑个不停，而且在你咬了一口、觉得布朗尼很好吃之后，我知道。然后你说，你呢，你不想要一块吗？
And I'm like, I'm trying to watch my weight. I know. It was making us laugh. It's so hard. The brownies were good. They were very good. But this also made me think of, you know what I was eating at this time?
然后我说，我在控制体重。我知道。这把我们逗得太开心了。布朗尼很好吃。它们非常好吃。但这还让我想到了，你知道我当时在吃什么吗？
What? I was eating those lactation cookies. Did you make those? They were all the rage when I was postpartum. They were like an oatmeal cookie that you made with brewers yeast and coconut oil. And they were supposed to help you with your milk production. And so, I was eating these cookies all the time. Right. So it was really good to eat that chocolate brownie. Like a break from those. Yeah. What I remembered most about this scene is how tickled we got and it was you and I having the dialogue just between the two of us. So that meant everyone was waiting for us to finish
什么？我在吃那些催乳曲奇。那是你做的吗？当我产后时，它们超级风靡。它们就像是一种用啤酒酵母和椰子油做成的燕麦饼干。它们据说能帮你的乳汁分泌。所以，我当时一直在吃这些饼干。没错。所以能吃到那块巧克力布朗尼真的很棒。就像是从那些饼干里解脱出来一样。是的。我对这场戏印象最深的是我们笑得有多开心，而且当时只有你和我两个人之间的对话。这意味着所有人都得等我们把台词说完。
our lines. Yeah. And we kept laughing. And I am telling you, you can see John check out. If you look at his face, he's just like, oh my God, are they going to get through this? It's so true. Well, this cold open ends with Pam trying to give cash to people. Yeah. And Jim's like, no, it's done. Stop, stop, don't get it. You didn't bring in any brownies. It's fine. Oh, but Angela, I have my catch. What? My background catch, when Dwight is surprised that Angela has come into work and he says, you just had our baby, our collective baby. Yeah. Kelly has really great nail polish on and you can see it over Dwight's shoulder.
对。我们一直笑个不停。我跟你说，你能看出约翰出戏了。如果你看他的表情，他简直就像是，天哪，他们能把这段演完吗？确实如此。好吧，这个冷开头以帕姆试图给人们发钱而结束。对。然后吉姆说，不，已经结束了。停，停，别拿了。你又没带布朗尼来。没关系。哦，不过安吉拉，我有我的彩蛋。什么？我的背景彩蛋是，当德怀特对安吉拉来上班感到惊讶并说“你刚生了我们的孩子，我们的共同孩子”时。是的。凯莉涂的指甲油非常好看，从德怀特的肩膀越过去刚好能看到。
Oh, it's really great. That's it. Okay. Super important catch. Well, the episode's going gonna start in Andy's office. He's got some big news for Dwight. Dwight's like, listen, if you're making me head of sales again, so help me.
哦，真的很漂亮。就是这样。好吧。超级重要的彩蛋。好了，这一集要从安迪的办公室开始了。他给德怀特带来了一个大消息。德怀特说，听着，如果你想让我再次当销售主管，那我可饶不了你。
I guess that's been happening a lot. But he's like, no, no, no, this is real. Dwight has been tasked with assembling a special team to go to Tallahassee for three weeks to develop and launch a chain of saber stores. So I guess what they're selling in the saber stores are the tablets, the new pyramid tablets, and printers? Possibly. But this is the best news Dwight's had in a long, long time.
我想这种事发生过很多次。但他却说，不，不，不，这是真的。德怀特被委任组建一个特别团队去塔拉哈西待三周，负责开发和推出一系列世博连锁店。所以我想他们在世博商店里卖的是平板电脑，那些新的金字塔平板电脑，还有打印机？可能是的。但这绝对是德怀特很长很长时间以来听到的最好的消息。
As Dwight's doing all of his celebrating, did anyone else see the Valentine's gift basket over Andy shoulder? Yes, I'm glad you're bringing it up. It's unopened. It's there the whole entire episode, unopened. Is this for Jessica? That's what I wanted to know. It was it for him? Is he giving it to someone? It has a bear in it. I don't know. It's there the whole time. Dwight is now going to share that he's having one of these perfect moments in his life. In fact, it's called perfect and schlog. Yes. Have you ever experienced perfect and schlog in your life? I think I experience it every week when I come here.
在德怀特进行各种庆祝的时候，有没有人看到安迪肩膀后面的那个情人节礼品篮？是的，我很高兴你提到了这个。它是没拆封的。它就在那里待了整整一集，都没拆封。这是给杰西卡的吗？这正是我想知道的。这是给他的吗？他是要送给别人吗？里面有一只熊。我不知道。它一直都在那儿。德怀特现在要分享他正经历着人生中一个完美的时刻。事实上，这叫完美时刻（perfect and schlog）。是的。你的人生中经历过完美时刻吗？我觉得我每次来这里都在经历它。
That's what I feel like. I feel like minus my broken shoulder. I am in perfect and schlog right now. Perfect and schlog. Yeah. I'm just really thankful and I love this chapter of my life. Same. I was curious if it was a real term. And I found a very interesting thread online of German speakers who love the office and wanted to get to the bottom of us using this word as well.
我就是这种感觉。我觉得除了我骨折的肩膀外。我现在正处于完美时刻。完美时刻。是的。我真的很感恩，我热爱我人生的这个阶段。我也是。我很想知道这是一个真实的词吗。我在网上发现了一个非常有趣的讨论串，里面有喜欢《办公室》的德语母语者，他们也想弄清楚我们为什么会使用这个词。
They all said it doesn't exist in the German language, but one entry had an interesting theory. Marco says, I'm a huge fan of the office and actually from a German-speaking country, Switzerland. So as some of you have pointed out correctly, there is no word in the German language that sounds like perfect inshlog. But as the English-speaking folks often pronounce German words in this particular way, I just thought of something that sounds familiar. Oh! Perfector Einschlag. Marco goes on to say that maybe this isn't what inspired the writers, but this is his theory. Perfector Einschlag means perfect impact.
他们都说德语里根本没有这个词，但其中一条评论提出了一个有趣的理论。马尔科说，我是《办公室》的超级粉丝，实际上来自一个讲德语的国家，瑞士。正如你们中的一些人正确指出的那样，德语里没有任何发音听起来像“perfect inshlog”的词。但由于说英语的人经常用这种特定方式发音德语单词，我突然想到了一个听起来很熟悉的发音。哦！Perfector Einschlag。马尔科接着说，也许这并不是启发编剧的灵感来源，但这只是他的理论。“Perfector Einschlag”意味着完美的冲击。
And if you ask me, Marco says says, it's a pretty good description of a perfect and outstanding situation. That's very interesting. My question that I didn't look up is does schlug mean pork anus? It did not look up pork anus. I thought about it and was like, no. Yeah, no, right?
如果你问我，马尔科说，这是对完美杰出局面的一个相当不错的描述。这太有趣了。我没有查证的问题是，“schlug”是不是指猪肛门？我没有去查猪肛门。我当时想了想，然后觉得，算了。对，没有，对吧？
You didn't want to Google that. I didn't want to Google that. Because Dwight does say perfect and schlug could also mean perfect pork anus, but that's not what he's talking about. Interesting. Aaron is now gonna give Andy his faxes of the day and he gets so many faxes.
你不想去谷歌搜那个。我才不想去谷歌搜呢。因为德怀特确实说过“perfect and schlog”也可能意味着“完美的猪肛门”，但这不是他在谈论的。有意思。亚伦现在要给安迪送当天的传真，他收到了好多传真。
Yeah, why do you need so many faxes if you have email? I don't know, but he's gonna say, I've got some facts for you. Lady does Andy like a fast fact? Did I fact check his facts? I fact checked his facts. We both fact checked his facts. We both fact checked his fast facts. All right, let's see if we got the same answers.
37|||对啊，既然有了电子邮件，为什么还需要那么多传真？我不知道，但他会说：“我有几个事实要告诉你。”女士，安迪喜欢快问快答吗？我核实过他的事实了吗？我核实了他的事实。我们俩都核实了他的事实。我们俩都核实了他的快问快答。好吧，看看我们的答案是不是一样。
Okay, go. Okay, his first fact is that frogs can hear with their lungs. True, true. Yeah. Frogs have no external ears. The only way they can hear is by sound traveling through their body to the lungs and then it goes to the ear drums. That's what I learned. This is also true of salamanders.
38|||好吧，开始。好吧，他的第一个事实是青蛙可以用肺听声音。真的，真的。对。青蛙没有外耳。它们听到声音的唯一途径是声音通过身体传到肺部，然后传到耳膜。这是我学到的。蝾螈也是如此。
Okay. All right. What's the next one? Flamingos can have orgasms that last 30 minutes. False. False. Not true. But they do last up to 15 minutes. They have a decently long orgasm. They do. I got curious and wanted to know what animal has the longest orgasm. Oh, Lord, can I guess? Yeah. What mammal? A whale. No. It's an animal that walks on the earth.
39|||好的。好吧。下一个是什么？火烈鸟的高潮可以持续30分钟。假的。假的。不是真的。但它们确实能持续长达15分钟。它们有相当长的高潮。确实。我很好奇，想知道哪种动物的高潮时间最长。哦，天哪，我能猜吗？可以。什么哺乳动物？鲸鱼。不对。是一种在地上走的动物。
Very common. Animal. Humans? No. Monkeys. Humans have orgasms that last longer than 15 minutes. I don't know. You said very common. You said they're walking around. So what's more common than a bunch of people?
40|||非常普遍。动物。人类？不对。猴子。人类的高潮持续时间比15分钟长。我不知道。你说是非常普遍的。你说它们在到处走。那有什么比一群人更普遍的？
Pigs. Oh, God. The domestic pig on average, their orgasm lasts 30 minutes, but can go for as long as 90. Wow. Mm-hmm. Oh, my gosh. Well, that changes how I look at my bacon. Sure does. It really does. Oh my gosh. Well, that changes how I look at my bacon and shirt. It really does.
41|||猪。哦，天哪。家猪的高潮平均持续30分钟，但可以长达90分钟。哇。嗯哼。哦，天哪。这改变了我对培根的看法。确实如此。真的如此。哦，天哪。这改变了我对培根和衬衫的看法。真的如此。
Well, after Andy gives these partially true, partially false facts about animals, Andy and Aaron are going to discover they both have the same blinking little Valentine's Day pin. And Aaron's going to find out that Andy got it from Jessica. And they're going to exchange real gifts later, not gag gifts. Yeah. Aaron's gonna have a talking head where she says, while she thought something might happen with her
42|||好吧，在安迪给出了这些半真半假关于动物的事实后，安迪和亚伦将发现他们都有同一个一闪一闪的小情人节别针。亚伦将发现安迪是从杰西卡那里拿到的。他们稍后会交换真正的礼物，而不是恶作剧礼物。对。亚伦会有一个面对镜头的独白，她说，虽然她觉得她
and Andy, you know, he's still with Jessica, they even carpool to work. I'm sorry, one moment. Is it carpooling? If you don't go to the same location, is it carpooling? Is it carpooling where multiple people get in a car and then they go to the same destination?
43|||和安迪之间可能会发生点什么，你知道的，他仍然和杰西卡在一起，他们甚至拼车上班。抱歉，等一下。这算拼车吗？如果你不去同一个地方，这算拼车吗？这算拼车吗？多个人上了一辆车，然后他们去同一个目的地？
Carpooling isn't like driving around, dropping people off at different locations. I looked it up, I'm right, I'm just gonna say. I don't know why I'm posing it as a question. I became so annoyed that she referred to this practice of Jessica driving Andy to work and dropping him off as carpooling that I was like, I don't think that's carpooling. Did that carpooling meant sharing a car? Not according to the definition of carpooling. Because
44|||拼车不就像到处开车，把人送到不同地方吗？我查过了，我是对的，我只想这么说。我不知道我为什么要把它作为一个问题提出。我对她把杰西卡开车送安迪去上班并把他放下这种做法称为拼车感到非常恼火，以至于我想，我觉得那不叫拼车。拼车是指共用一辆车吗？根据拼车的定义并非如此。因为
that's sort of I thought the whole point is to lessen your carbon footprint. So you hop in a car with someone else so you're only using one vehicle, which lessens traffic. So those are all great things are just not called carpooling. What's it called? I don't know. Carpooling is when you go around
45|||我觉得重点是减少碳足迹。所以你跳上别人的车，这样你只用一辆车，从而减少交通。所以这些都是很好的事情，只是不叫拼车。那叫什么？我不知道。拼车是当你到处跑
and you get people and then you all end at the same place. That's a carpool. Oh. Otherwise, it's giving someone a ride somewhere. Like car sharing, maybe car sharing. Car sharing. Yeah. Like you carpooled me to work.
46|||接人，然后你们都在同一个地方结束。那才叫拼车。哦。否则，这就叫顺便载别人一程。比如拼车，也许是拼车。拼车。对。就像你拼车送我上班一样。
When my shoulder was broken, you picked me up, and then we both came to the same destination. But if you picked me up and dropped me off at my physical therapy, and then you went to the grocery store, we're not carpooling to physical therapy, we are car sharing. We're car sharing. Right, so go to the bottom of it.
47|||当我肩膀骨折时，你接了我，然后我们俩来到了同一个目的地。但如果你接了我，把我送到物理治疗的地方，然后你去杂货店，我们不是拼车去物理治疗，我们是拼车（共用车）。我们在拼车。好吧，那我们追根究底吧。
Go to the bottom of it. Go to the bottom of it. Sometimes I get a, you know, I know, I know. I know, I know. I know. Well, Darrell is gonna return to his desk, and he's gonna find a homemade knitted hat with a card from Val.
48|||追根究底。追根究底。有时我得到一个，你知道的，我知道，我知道。我知道，我知道。我知道。好吧，达里尔要回到他的办公桌前，他会发现一顶手工针织帽，还有瓦尔的一张卡片。
And he's like, hmm, is this a friendship beanie or let's get it poppin' beanie? Yeah. He's gonna decide to match her gift with Romantic Gift of his own. Mm-hmm. Meanwhile, Dwight's gonna invite Pam to Tallahassee. He's chosen her to be part of the team.
49|||他想，嗯，这是一顶友谊帽还是让我们关系更进一步的帽子？yeah。他决定用他自己的浪漫礼物来回应她的礼物。嗯哼。与此同时，德怀特要邀请帕姆去塔拉哈西。他选中她成为团队的一员。
Yes. This is huge. But she has to wear a one-piece swimsuit to his barbecue. I want to say, I don't know if you noticed on my computer in this scene, but there's this like, Fakey office supply document. It was several pages long. It was like a fake office catalog. This was a new prop that I got for my computer, and it was my favorite fakie computer screen prop for the whole show. I was obsessed with it. You're gonna see it forever on my computer now
50|||是的。这太重大了。但她必须穿连体泳衣去他的烧烤派对。我想说，我不知道你有没有注意到在这个场景中我电脑上的东西，但有这样一个像虚构的办公用品文档。它有好几页长。它就像一个虚构的办公室目录。这是我为我的电脑弄的一个新道具，这是整部剧中我最喜欢的虚构电脑屏幕道具。我对此着迷了。你现在永远都会在我的电脑上看到它
because it was my favorite thing to fake do. Okay, I just scroll through this. It was like a PDF that they invented for me, and then I had these worksheets. So my background fakie work was me doing like, I guess I was ordering office supplies for our office supply company. I don't know. Well, you guys that were in the middle of the bullpen,
51|||因为这是我最喜欢假装在做的事情。好吧，我只是滚动浏览了这个。这就像他们为我发明的PDF，然后我有这些工作表。所以我的背景虚构工作是我在做，我想我是在为我们的办公用品公司订购办公用品。我不知道。好吧，你们这些坐在办公区中间的人，
your screens were seen more than ours over in accounting. Yeah. I had one little page they designed that I could pop up, but mostly my computer was never seen. I had like a few icons on my desktop, and if we were gonna see my computer screen, which as you said happened often, I could pick one of these things,
52|||你们的屏幕比我们会计部的屏幕被看到的更多。Yeah。我设计了一小页我可以弹出的内容，但大部分时间我的电脑都没被看到。我的桌面上有一些图标，如果我们能看到我的电脑屏幕，正如你所说经常发生的那样，我可以选择这些东西之一，
but I became like slightly obsessed with this one document, and I think you're gonna see it all the time. Okay, they designed it while it was gone. I remember getting to work and be like, what is this? I love it. That was gone. I remember getting to work and be like, what is this? I love it. That was amazing. Thank you so much. Well, down in the warehouse,
53|||但我对这份文档变得有点着迷，我想你一直都会看到它。好吧，他们在我离开的时候设计了它。我记得去上班时想，这是什么？我喜欢它。那是离开。我记得去上班时想，这是什么？我喜欢它。那太棒了。非常感谢。好吧，在仓库里，
Darryl is gonna tell Val that he loves his beanie. It's like sweatpants for his head, and then Nate walks up wearing a beanie also. And Darryl looks around everyone in the warehouse has a knitted beanie. All from Val. I gotta call BS here for a second. Okay. Nate's beanie does not look like it was handmade.
54|||达里尔要告诉瓦尔他喜欢他的毛线帽。这就像是他头部的运动裤，然后内特走过来，也戴着一顶毛线帽。达里尔环顾四周，仓库里的每个人都有一顶针织毛线帽。全都是瓦尔送的。我在这里得指出这是胡说八道。好吧。内特的毛线帽看起来不像是手工制作的。
It looks like a machine beanie. Darryl looks handmade. I'm there with you on that one. Nate's, come on. I asked Steve Burgess about this. I got the same thing. Steve said we cheated a little. Oh, yes, Steve.
55|||它看起来像机器织的毛线帽。达里尔的看起来是手工制作的。在这点上我和你观点一致。内特的，拜托。我问过史蒂夫·伯吉斯关于这件事。我得到了同样的回答。史蒂夫说我们作弊了一点点。哦，是的，史蒂夫。
We noticed only the beanie that Darryl received was hand-knit by someone. He's not sure who did it, but Phil Shea had it done. All the others were purchased. Mm-hmm. Well, Darryl is now too embarrassed to give Val the gift he bought, so he says it was for Nate. And they are beautiful, elegant, cashmere, winter gloves. I mean, Darryl.
56|||我们注意到只有达里尔收到那顶毛线帽是某人手工针织的。他不确定是谁做的，但菲尔·谢伊让人做了这个。所有其他的都是买的。嗯哼。好吧，达里尔现在太尴尬了，不好意思把买的礼物送给瓦尔，所以他说那是给内特的。那是美丽、优雅、羊绒的冬季手套。我是说，达里尔。
And the card. Thank you so much. Oh my gosh, the card is so sweet as well. Ah, Nate's very moved. Yeah, I thought Mark was so funny in the show. So funny when he was like, ah, Darryl, I know. I appreciate you too. The look on bag's face.
57|||还有卡片。非常感谢。哦，天哪，卡片也太甜了。啊，内特非常感动。Yeah，我觉得马克在剧里太搞笑了。太搞笑了，当他说，啊，达里尔，我知道。我也感激你。包袋（指代Nate）脸上的表情。
He holds this stare. I know. That is so perfect for so long. They did such a great job, the two of them. Dwight is now going to have a talking head where he says that his first task as special project manager will be assembling a crack team. He's going to need people that are loyal. He starts kind of scanning the bull pin. In the background, Creed puts his hand
58|||他保持着这个凝视的表情。我知道。真是太完美了，持续了那么久。他们两个做得太棒了。德怀特现在要有一个独白，他说他作为特别项目经理的第一项任务将是组建一个精英团队。他需要忠诚的人。他开始环顾办公区。在背景中，克里德把手放进
in his mouth. That was scripted. Really? Yep. It said, Creed puts his hand in his mouth. Was it scripted that the people in the kitchen were trying to touch their tongues to the tip of his nose? Yes. Scripted. Can you do that? I can't do it. No. I can't do it. I wonder if Daniel Radcliffe can do it. Oh, flower-dust. I remember when he was just asked. Yeah.
59|||嘴里。那是剧本里写好的。真的吗？是的。上面写着，克里德把手放进嘴里。厨房里的人试图用舌头去舔他鼻尖是剧本安排的吗？是的。剧本写的。你能做到吗？我做不到。不。我做不到。不知道丹尼尔·雷德克里夫能不能做到。哦，三叶草。我记得当他刚被问到。Yeah。
Cloverleaf tongue. Cloverleaf, I knew it was a plant. It was some kind of plant. Well, now we're going to have a big wrinkle in the story, which is that Jim is going to receive a text from Robert California telling him to bring his golf clubs to Florida. He's very confused, he doesn't wanna go to Florida. So Jim is like, what should I text back? Should I text back to question marks?
60|||三叶草舌。三叶草，我知道那是一种植物。那是某种植物。好吧，现在我们的故事里将有一个大的转折，那就是吉姆将收到罗伯特·加利福尼亚的一条短信，告诉他把高尔夫球杆带到佛罗里达。他非常困惑，他不想去佛罗里达。所以吉姆就像，我应该回什么短信？我应该回两个问号吗？
And Pam is like, no, no, that's too aggressive. That's like, what? I loved that Jenna. I loved your, what? We couldn't get through it. I loved it. You guys kept cracking up, but then also we all just started saying it.
61|||然后帕姆说，不，不，那太咄咄逼人了。那就像是，什么？我喜欢那个，珍娜。我喜欢你的，什么？我们演不下去了。我喜欢它。你们一直在笑，但后来我们也都开始这么说了。
Do you remember? I still say what? What? Yeah. Yeah. That became a bit. There's a blooper of it because the first time I did it, it was really big. And John just immediately like just tears came out of size.
62|||你记得吗？我还是会说，什么？什么？Yeah。Yeah。那成了一个梗。有一个相关的笑场花絮，因为我第一次做的时候，反应非常大。琼立刻就笑出了眼泪。
I was just, I was loving so hard. And we all were like, what was that? What did I just do? That was insane. It was very hard to get back to work. I loved this Jim Pamp storyline where they're trying to figure out how to compose a text together. It was so relatable to me.
63|||我当时笑得太厉害了。我们都在想，那是什么？我刚刚做了什么？太疯狂了。要重新开始工作非常困难。我喜欢吉姆和帕姆的这条故事线，他们试图一起弄清楚如何写一条短信。这对我来说太有共鸣了。
My husband really hates writing emails or text. He's just more of a talker. You know? And so he'll always be like, oh, we helped me with the text. I'm like, okay, that's so interesting. Lee is our text expert in our marriage. He's much better at putting together a text. There's always one, right? So Angela, we had a fan question from Kaitlyn in California about this scene, and I'm going to throw it to you. Kaitlyn asked, when Jim gets the first text from Robert California, what are Pam
64|||我丈夫真的很讨厌写电子邮件或短信。他更喜欢当面聊天。你知道吗？所以他总是会说，哦，帮我写个短信。我说，好吧，这太有趣了。李是我们婚姻中的短信专家。他更擅长组织短信。总有一个人是这样的，对吧？所以，安吉拉，我们有一个来自加州凯特琳的粉丝问题，关于这个场景，我要把它抛给你。凯特琳问，当吉姆收到罗伯特·加利福尼亚的第一条短信时，帕姆
and Aaron doing? They're cutting green paper at Pam's desk, but it never comes back. Was there a deleted scene that went with this? Caitlin, I was super curious about this too. I mean, remember how I said I was going to point out a few Valentine's things. Yes. I saw Andy's basket. Yes. You guys, of course, I saw the basket. You know I love baskets. What did I bring you today? Can I brought me the biggest baskets ever? She had said, okay, Ange, do you want some baskets that I have?
65|||和亚伦在做什么？他们在帕姆的桌子旁剪绿纸，但这个镜头再也没有出现过。有没有被删减的场景与此相关？凯特琳，我对这一点也超级好奇。我的意思是，还记得我说过我要指出几个情人节的小细节吗。是的。我看到了安迪的篮子。是的。你们大家，当然，我看到了篮子。你知道我喜欢篮子。我今天给你带了什么？我带来了有史以来最大的篮子吗？她曾说过，好吧，安吉，你想要我的一些篮子吗？
And I'm like, who are you talking to? Of course, I want your baskets. I was doing a deep clean. Yeah. And I had two extra giant baskets. You know, the kind that you put throw pillows and things in. I sent you a text that said, do you want two giant baskets that I don't need anymore? And before I could send you the picture,
66|||我说，你在跟谁说话？我当然想要你的篮子。我在做深度大扫除。Yeah。我有两个多出来的巨大篮子。你知道那种用来装抱枕之类的篮子。我给你发了一条短信，说你想要两个我不再需要的巨大篮子吗？在我能把照片发给你之前，
you wrote back yes. I know. I've been waiting them side on side. They're really big. Sam took a picture of us with them. I am very excited. I can only imagine what Josh is gonna say when I come home today with these giant baskets.
67|||你就回了“要”。我知道。我一直把它们并排放在一起。它们真的很大。萨姆拍下了我们和它们的合影。我很兴奋。我只能想象当我今天带着这些巨大的篮子回家时乔什会说什么。
He's gonna be like, where did you get these? But okay, Caitlin, sorry. My love of baskets got me chatted, but yes, okay, my other Valentine's background catch was exactly this scene, exactly what you're talking about, and I went to the shooting draft to get to the bottom of it, and here's what it said. Aaron has her chair pulled up to Pam's desk
68|||他会说，你从哪弄来的这些？但是好吧，凯特琳，抱歉。我对篮子的热爱让我聊远了，但是是的，好吧，我的另一个情人节背景彩蛋正是这个场景，也就是你正在谈论的那个，我去翻了拍摄剧本以查明真相，上面是这样写的：亚伦把椅子拉到帕姆的桌子旁
between Jim and Pam. We see a wall decoration of an angry gun toting Cupid. Pam says Cupid uses a bow and arrow, not a gun. Aaron says, who's Cupid? That's baby Jesus. Pam says, okay, you know what? Let's just do pink hearts. Red hearts.
69|||在吉姆和帕姆之间。我们看到一个墙面装饰是一个生气的、拿着枪的丘比特。帕姆说丘比特用的是弓箭，不是枪。亚伦说，谁是丘比特？那是小耶稣。帕姆说，好吧，你知道吗？我们还是做粉红色的心吧。红色的心。
That kind of thing. Aaron says, if you're not in a relationship, Valentine's Day isn't pink hearts. It's not even red. It's like gray, or dark brown, or blue. What's the color of want? Stanley, without even looking up, says Burgundy. Kathy looks over and says, oh, are you guys making more Valentine's decorations?
70|||诸如此类。亚伦说，如果你没有谈恋爱，情人节就不是粉红色的心。甚至都不是红色的。它就像灰色，或者深棕色，或者蓝色。渴望是什么颜色？斯坦利甚至没有抬头，说酒红色。凯西看过来，说，哦，你们是在做更多的情人节装饰吗？
Pam says just a couple for fun. Kathy says, I guess I didn't put up enough. Do you guys need any help? I'm pretty crafty. And then Kelly chimes in out of nowhere. Don't let her help. Whoa. Mm-hmm.
71|||帕姆说，就几个，好玩而已。凯西说，我猜我没有挂够。你们需要帮忙吗？我挺心灵手巧的。然后凯莉突然插话。别让她帮忙。哇。嗯哼。
So I guess Aaron didn't like all the red decorations, because for her Valentine's Day isn't about love, right? Right. So she's found some other construction paper. But I did want to point out, as soon as Stanley said that, I couldn't help but notice that Kelly, Pam, and Kathy are all wearing shades of burgundy, and Darrell's beanie is burgundy.
72|||所以我猜亚伦不喜欢所有红色的装饰，因为对她来说情人节无关爱情，对吧？对。所以她找了一些其他的彩色卡纸。但我确实想指出，就在斯坦利说完后，我不禁注意到凯莉、帕姆和凯西都穿着不同色调的酒红色，而达里尔的毛线帽也是酒红色的。
It's very funny that you mentioned what people were wearing because I clocked three things that I found very curious. You can see them in an upcoming scene. Should I save it? Yeah. All right, I'll save it. Well, let's take a break because Jenna, when we get back, I have a fun thing to share from the script about this scene between Dwight and Andy. Ooh, great! We are back and Dwight is in Andy's office and they are negotiating over who the telehassy
73|||你提到大家的穿着太有趣了，因为我注意到三件让我觉得非常好奇的事情。你可以在接下来的一个场景中看到它们。我是不是应该先留着不说？Yeah。好吧，那我就留着。好吧，我们休息一下吧，因为珍娜，当我们回来时，我有一个从剧本里分享的有趣事情，关于德怀特和安迪之间的这个场景。噢，太棒了！我们回来了，德怀特在安迪的办公室里，他们正在协商谁将成为塔拉哈西
team will be. Dwight has some ideas, Andy has other ideas. Yeah. Dwight wants to take Darryl, Phyllis, Toby, Angela, and Oscar. I don't know if you notice, but he has handed Andy a folder of photos of each of us, eight by 10 photos of Dwight's pics. And I was very curious, I could see there was writing next to the photos. I went to the script, here's what it said.
74|||团队的成员。德怀特有一些想法，安迪有别的想法。Yeah。德怀特想带达里尔、菲莉丝、托比、安吉拉和奥斯卡。我不知道你有没有注意到，他递给安迪一个文件夹，里面是我们每个人的照片，那是德怀特挑选的8x10英寸照片。我很好奇，我看到照片旁边有字。我看了剧本，上面是这样写的：
Interior Andy's office. Andy is looking through Dwight's material, which is several sheets of paper. Each paper has a photo of the person he wants and on the side, a list of their special skills, personal history, foes, first appearance, and weaknesses. I was like, I wanna see! I wanna see what they wrote on these pieces of paper.
I was really curious what was gonna happen to Dunder Mifflin if Dwight was taking both Oscar and Angela. Who's doing the accounting for us? I think that leaves us Kevin. I think this is Andy's point. Andy's like, um, can I interest you in someone less essential like a creed or a meriteth perhaps? Dwight says, are you kidding me? I'm supposed to get in an airplane with those ninkum poops. We'd never get off the runway. I'm like, why does he go to traveling with them? That's his first thought.
How do I travel with Meredith and Creed? I mean, he's not making a bad point. I know. Andy wants Dwight's team to be Darryl Phyllis, Kathy Kelly, and Kevin. Dwight has a talking head where he says he's just been given a chain with three-week links. Have you ever tried to use a chain with three week links? He has and now he no longer owns an Arctic wolf.
Oh boy. Well, we got a fan question from Melita in Colorado who said, were there any alts for things that Dwight lost on a chain with three week links? Oh, Melita, you know us so well. Yeah. You know our writers must have had a whole candy bag of things. Well, I looked it up and there was one alt where Dwight said, have you ever tried to use a chain with three weak links I have and now I no longer own a bear? I much prefer Arctic Wolf personally, but there was another must shoot talking head that could have gone here, where
Dwight would have said, Darryl? Good worker. Wanted him all along. Phyllis? No picnic, but given the options, she's fine. Kelly? Has her moments look wise? Otherwise useless? Kevin? Sweet guy? Like him a lot? Worse than useless? Kathy? Barely even a person. Couldn't pick her out of a lineup if I had a gun to my head. No, this will not stand. Kathy also had a deleted talking head here. Hmm, where we find out a little bit about her past.
She says, well, Pam's back so I'm out of a job. Funny thing is, if I had just married Doug, I wouldn't have this problem, but I'm not attracted to Doug. Hey, remind me the next time I forget, Kathy, you were not happy with Doug. Doug, who's Doug? I don't know. Did he propose?
You know, I've been trading text messages with Lindsay because we very much want to have her on the show. I just keep texting her more and more questions. You're going to have a very, very long interview. Yeah. Because this Kathy character is such an enigma to me. There's so many things that they wrote, so many things that we shot that we didn't end up using. I got to hear her perspective on this.
I know, every week there's all of this footage of her in deleted scenes and stuff in the shooting draft that we shot. So Pam and Jim are now in the break room and they're still working on this text to Robert California. They might be overthinking it. They needed to get away so that they could compose
this text, really concentrate on it. But another reason why we're in the break room, Angela, was because Dave Rogers said if we filmed in here, it would shorten my work day because it would be a separate scene from the rest of the story. I really appreciated that. He did that for me. Like I said, there were a lot of ways that our cast and crew helped me get through these early weeks back at work postpartum, and this was one of them. When I saw us in the break room, it just reminded me of that choice that he made for me. It felt good. Oh, Davis is such a nice guy. I know. I have to shout him out. Yeah.
Well, yes. So Jim and Pam are still working on this text. They've decided to make it more about golf. Let's emphasize the golf back in Scranton, not in Florida. Yes. And then Jim says, you know what? Wait, I just feel weird. back in Scranton, not in Florida, right? Mm-hmm. And then Jim says, you know what, wait, I just feel weird. I should just call him. Kelly says, you want to call someone that texted you?
Do you want to drive them away? I mean, ugh. Oh my gosh, lady, I looked up texting versus calling online. There is a lot, a lot, a lot about this on the internet. Is Kelly right? People have strong opinions. Wow. I mean, ultimately, what it all comes down to is sort of
what you want out of the relationship, right? But I found this great article on Greater Good Magazine's website. It was titled, Should You Call or Text? Science weighs in. Science, you know, I love some science. I know. What does science say about this? There was a study that suggested we undervalue the bonding enjoyment we get from hearing someone's voice. According to the article, we'd be better off picking up the phone or setting up a video call
where we can actually hear another person's voice than texting or emailing. Lady, this is why we do our audio memos. I know. Because we can hear each other in our storytelling. That's exactly right. In this study, they found that people who spoke on the phone were happier with the exchange, felt closer to the other person than those who emailed. the exchange felt closer to the other person than those who emailed. I mean, that makes total sense. It's very interesting. So the voice in particular helps you to connect with other people, hearing someone's voice. Science.
Science. Science says, call, don't text. But that's not what Kelly says. No. Kelly says, are you crazy? I have a little personal catch from this scene. Okay. I am wearing a new necklace and new earrings.
And I loved this necklace and earrings so much that I took both of them when we wrapped. Oh, what is the necklace? It's like a little tree. And then the earring is just a filigree dangle, but it was like I came back from maternity leave and I had this new PDF document on my computer and I had this new necklace and earrings and I guess I don't know I became very sentimental about these new items.
Darryl is now gonna receive a phone call maybe someone's voice he doesn't want to hear. Val's boyfriend is calling. Yes, Brandon. We did not even know Val had a boyfriend, but he wants to send some flowers and he needs the warehouse address. Yeah. Darryl says I just need to find a pen. Brandon says why do you need a pen?
He says, hey, I have my reasons. Well, Val's boyfriend was voiced by actor Jerry Minor. He was actually on set with us, calling from a phone off camera. And I don't want to give any spoilers, but you'll be seeing more of him. Yes. Which I was very excited about because I've known Jerry for a very long time. Yeah, Jerry's hilarious. It's time for a conference room meeting for the Tallahassee team.
But they're not going to make it to the conference room because Dwight is purposely, very manipulatively, listing the people who are going to Tallahassee. Sabotage. He is doing some sabotage. And he starts naming Andy's picks. Well, people want to know what was the criteria for these picks. And Dwight says you're going to have to ask Andy. Oh, Andy does not like this. He's like, guys, guys, guys, guys. This was the scene, Angela, where I made some interesting observations about
wardrobe or maybe not so interesting, but I made them. I will let you know. Let me hear them. Dwight is wearing a tan short sleeve shirt, not mustard. I noticed that. In this episode. I noticed that. Okay. Kathy is wearing heavy gray tights and a burgundy sweater. Yeah, her outfit is mismatched. Finally, Darryl is wearing a light blue t-shirt under a white button down. This is something I'd not seen before, where you wear usually a white t-shirt under a button down of another color,
but do you wear a colored shirt under a white button down? I don't know, lady. Is that a thing? I don't know. I don't know either. Well Is that a thing? I don't know. I don't know either. Well, Darryl's doing it. He is making his own fashion statement.
He is. Those were my fashion catches for special project. Well, Andy didn't realize so many people wanted to go to Florida. So he says I'm open to hearing anyone who wishes to plea their case. Dwight thinks they should take several hours to come up with their statements. Andy says 30 minutes. And then Creed says, I'm out.
Yeah, he doesn't have 30 minutes to spend on this pitch. A Creed talking head would have followed this moment. Please tell me what it does. Right after Creed says, I'm out, here's his talking head. Florida's 13th in education, 13th in tourism, 13th in cleanliness, it's literally the worst state in the union. That is nowhere I thought that talking head was going. I thought maybe he was going to be superstitious about all the 13s, but clearly Creed doesn't
know how many states are in the United States because to be 13 out of 50 is not the worst. And I didn't Google it. I actually don't know where Florida now lies in any stats because this was written a long time ago. But I was also so curious like, when is Creed researching Florida? What is Creed's life? Oh, Creed one of the other things in the scene that cracked me up is when you see Phyllis walking by as she's preparing and she says I have a new swimsuit I need to break in did you hear her say no I was wondering if that was scripted. I thought it was so cute and this is what it said in the shooting draft There are quick shots of people preparing their presentations Kelly sits nervously outside Andy's door, Stanley talks to himself while pacing, Ryan listens
to his iPod, I shut, head bobbing, Andy pokes his head out the door. Hmm, so that little bit with Phyllis was totally improvised, and whatever Kate as Meredith is starting to say, I just thought it was cute. Well, now Jim and Pam are back at their desks and they're working on a new draft of his text to Robert California. They finally figure it out. They decide to just sort of be honest.
Be like, hey, my wife just had a baby. We have a newborn and a toddler. I should be around to help out. And Robert texts back LOL. To which Aaron just starts laughing. I think she took it as a command. Yes. At least she knew what LOL stood for. Well, I have the cutest story about LOL. Okay. It's so cute. My dad, when he was alive, you know, these little abbreviations were just sort of happening. People were emailing and stuff.
Be like, hey, my wife just had a baby. We have a newborn and a toddler. I should be around to help out. And Robert texts back LOL. To which Aaron just starts laughing. I think she took it as a command. Yes. At least she knew what LOL stood for. Well, I have the cutest story about LOL. Okay. It's so cute. My dad, when he was alive, you know, these little abbreviations were just so sort of happening. People were emailing and stuff.
And my dad started signing his emails, LOL, dad. And I thought, what is that? I was like, dad, you know, that means lots of laughs. And he goes, oh, I thought it meant lots of love. Oh, I knew. And then he said, when he learned it was lots of laughs, then he started signing his emails, AML, which he made up himself, which just means all my love. So sorry. I know. After he passed away, my sister made us each little
necklaces that had the little gold bar and said AML. Oh my, I know. Wow, I know. And whenever I see LOL, I always think of my dad. Oh, I love that. So cute, so sweet. Mm-hmm, I got choked up. I know, I know. Gets me to. Well, while the group is preparing their pitches,
Dwight has a talking head where he says he's already chosen his team. Yes. He's going to take Darryl, Oscar, Angela, Phyllis, and Toby. And while he might only have influence over the decision, that's all that Balth's or Gladfield had, and now no one eats owls for Thanksgiving. I did Google this. I did too. I did too. I Google to people eat owls. It's illegal to eat owls. It's illegal.
I mean, the Migratory Bird Treaty Act, which was in 1992, 1980. We did not both learn about this Migratory Bird Treaty Act. We did. You cannot consume, possess, including their eggs, our capture or sell, our trade or transport, any protected migratory, birth species, which includes owls and hawks, Yes. ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... Yes, Eagles can be hunted for food and their eggs can be eaten by indigenous people. But only if their tribe is federally recognized and only if they have a permit from the federal government. Yes, exactly. In the only time you can, I guess, take action against the other ones, is if you have authorization by the Department of Interior, US Fish and Wildlife Service, like
if there's an overpopulation or sometimes, but it's got to be authorized. Yeah. So, I guess, Doni and Owl. Don't do anything to an owl. I mean, there's Mr. Meanor offenses, felony offenses. You can pay a big, wop and fine or even get gel time. Wow.
But as you probably found as well, bolts are glad field is a fictitious name. Yes. And no one ever ate an owl for Thanksgiving or even considered eating an owl for Thanksgiving. We made that up, yes. But our Googling led us to this migratory bird's act.
Tree. Yeah, somehow it also led me to, if you have birds that are hunters, they can be real gross tasting. Yes, I read that too. That they don't taste good anyway. Yeah. Things I didn't know I was going to learn this week. Things I didn't know.
Well, Ryan's going to now do his PowerPoint to pitch himself. I loved it. Oh my gosh, BJ was so good in the scene. So good. When he is Ryan is like, again, take one of us, but not both. Yeah Then it's Kevin's turn. He clearly has a gambling problem. Brian again, I was just so blown away by the whole cast this episode Brian is Kevin when he's talking about episode. Brian is Kevin when he's talking about placing the beds. Maybe there's a mismatch.
He did such a good job. He does this weird little thing with his tongue. Kevin cannot wait to get to the dog track. Then we have Toby, super sad sack Toby. Yes, he suffers from sad, which is seasonal effective disorder. Yeah. It is real. Yes, it is. Moods do change with the seasons. And for some people, this is really can be serious. I had heard about this, but I read a little more about it because I know that Andy and Dwight make a joke of it, but I just wanted to like stand up for people who suffer from this, because especially people who have bipolar disorder are at an increased risk of seasonal effective disorder,
that truly the spring and summer months can trigger more mania and the fall and winter months can trigger more depression and anxiety and irritability. And so this is like, if you're feeling this in you, you're not crazy. I actually crave being outside. If I'm inside for too long, I start to feel a little blue. I got to get out, I got to see the sky. And I know it's not exactly the same, but I know how that affects me, just needing to be able to see the sky and get outside. Yes. Next up, someone who really wants to get outside in Florida is Florida Stanley. The happiest we've ever seen Stanley is Florida Stanley.
Where did he get this outfit? Suddenly in the middle of the day. Is this what? Did he go home? 30 minutes? Yeah, I think he went home and changed. Completely changed clothes. Florida Stanley is going to give a very enthusiastic sales pitch here. The scene was longer and we would have found out a very interesting tidbit about Stanley. Okay? Stanley would have gone on to say,
My boy lives in Telehassy. We haven't talked in a while, but this might be what I need to get my family back together. What? Yeah! Wait, what? Stanley has a son that lives in Tallahassee. He has an ex-wife?
Besides his current ex-wife, and, er, wait, he has a wife, a girlfriend. And an ex-wife? And an ex-wife with a son in Florida? I mean, that's what was in the shooting draft. That's a curve ball. I know. Well, in the kitchen, Pam, for a reason that feels totally unmotivated to me, tells Jim
he needs to go to Florida for three weeks, and assures him that she'll be just fine at home with her mom and sister at the house. I'm happy that in this scene, we acknowledge that Pam has a sister, but this kind of came out of left field for me. I guess does Pam think that Jim just shouldn't stand up to Robert? I guess she thinks, was there a scene missing here? I don't know, but all of a sudden Pam's like, you need to go to Florida. And then Jim is going to jump on that, All of a sudden, Pam's like, you need to go to Florida. And then Jim is gonna jump on that. Like, he's gonna charge into Andy's office
and be like, I'm going to Florida. Look, I have a text from Robert California. I'm going. It just seemed like very like an abrupt change for me from these guys. It seemed like a very quick decision. Yes. Yeah, I think.
I don't know. Yeah, because you're like, where's the scene where Maybe they're like maybe this gets you a promotion. Maybe it gets us for money. Maybe you should go Yeah, maybe there was an extra text that they're dealing with from Robert California since LOL Yeah, like something that was like Jim. I really need you here. I don't know Something that would motivate Pam to say, I think you need to go to Florida. Yeah.
It felt a little random to me when I saw it. I was like, oh, he's going to Florida. Remember, I was in a bit of a haze when we were shooting this. So sometimes I'm watching these episodes and I like, it's like I'm doing it for the first time. Andy is gonna address the bullpen and finally reveal the Tallahassee group.
It will be Kathy, Stanley, Ryan, Aaron, and Jim. Rain's reactions as Dwight were so hilarious. I looked at the script because I wanted to know what it said. All it said was that Dwight takes a big breath gathering himself, then walks out and screams. So all those little reactions when Dwight is like kind of like putting his fist to his mouth and cursing, yeah, that was all Reigns' performance. Well, that explains this fan catch from Brandon and Illinois who said, at 15 minutes and 50 seconds, when Andy announces the official Florida picks,
Dwight's swearing triggers so many people to break. Yes, Lindsay, Leslie and BJ are all smiling a little too strongly for their characters in that moment. I think I saw BJ smile and look right at camera, like as BJ, where he's like, are we keeping that? That was amazing. Like I could see his editing brain. Right, like is that staying in?
Yeah. Well, there would have been a Dwight talking head here. This is what it said in the script. Let's see. My team is Stanley the town grump, Ryan a never-ending failure. Kathy the random temp, Aaron a mayor receptionist,
and Jim, my worst enemy. This is who I have to take to Florida and manage. I'd be better off taking five of my cows. I may be laugh. Well, now Dwight is gonna take his Florida group into the conference room, which he has, I guess turned into a humid, hot and muggy full of mosquitoes, tons of posters that he thinks depicts Florida.
This is like Florida orientation for Dwight. Did you catch the Florida facts he has on the poster board? No. Okay, it says, just written in no particular order on poster board, scar faces, heat strokes, theme parks, brick hogan, sinkholes, molde obese people, geriatric capital of the world. Hmm, those are Florida facts. Those are his Florida facts. According to Dwight K. Shrewd.
Dwight is doing all of this because he's hoping that people will drop out of the trip, but it doesn't work. Nobody caves. Nobody presses the taboo buzzer, which is how to get out of the trip. Right. There's some funny bloopers with that taboo buzzer. I bet. Back in the warehouse, Nate has made Darryl a whole bunch of sort of friendship coupons.
You know how? I was like, when you're dating and you have the little coupon books, like, this is good for one back rub. Yes. Well, for Nate, they're called Nate Ponds. Yes. And Daryl's rich in them. I had an idea for the ultimate like coupon
that like a husband could give a wife. Okay. Now, I'm gonna preface this by saying that I'm making some assumptions, but probably some correct assumptions about invisible labor that happens in a relationship with men and women who are parents. Okay. I dare a man to give this coupon to his wife for Valentine's Day, Mother's Day Christmas, whatever it is. What is it?
It says, for one year, I will read and deal with every email from our children's school. No, there's so many. There's so many. I will take this on. This is no longer your responsibility for a full year. That means if we get an email about picture day, I'm going to put picture day on my calendar. I'm going to make sure that the kids close are clean. Yeah, that their hair is cut for picture day. I'm on it Anything feel trip. I've got that parent teacher conferences. I'm guessing them. Yes. Oh was there a request to bring in something for teacher appreciation day? I'm on it. I've got it every single email from the school is my responsibility for one year. You get one year off. Coupon.
Wow. If you do it, write me a letter. Let me know how it goes. I want to know your wife's reaction. And then report back in a year. Report back in a year. I suggested this to some friends. We were having a barbecue
at our house and I said, what do you think of this coupon idea? The wife actually had a mild panic. She was like, they both panicked in the moment. Like, it was so clear to me, right? And she was like, I don't know if I could not read them. Like, I don't know if I can turn that over, right? But this is the reason why we get stuck with all this invisible labor is because we don't turn it over and also because we don't sometimes allow our husbands to step up. Yeah.
I think this would be a really great exercise. I don't know. Let me know. That's definitely a juicy coupon. That's a juice pond. That's a juice pond. Darryl is gonna compliment Val on the bouquet of roses that she received
and she says they're from my mom. And he's like, oh really? Cause your mom called me, had kind of a deep voice. Brandon was the name your mom gave and she's like, yep, that's my mom. Well, now Darryl knows where he stands because Val's lying about her boyfriend. It was a love beanie. How, what is going on? Dwight has cleaned out the conference room now of all of his weird Florida stuff and he's
gonna have a real meeting because no one dropped out here as his team and guess what? People surprise him. They are eager, they are engaged, they're presenting good ideas. Yeah, Dwight is coming around, he's like, you know what? Maybe this isn't such a bad team after all. Perfect in schlock. I loved this conference room scene. It warmed my heart, me too. I'm excited for them. I loved how earnest and excited everyone was. Erin is gonna have a talking head
where she says she's going to Florida and she's not coming back. Ooh, Miles McNut really liked that talking head. He liked that Erin was doing this for other reasons. Yeah. Again, you can't go there with logic. Like, why Saber would put together this specific team of people for this specific project. Yes, it makes no sense that we need both Aaron and Kathy. Yes. Two admins. Mm-hmm. One of whom is not a permanent employee.
where she says she's going to Florida and she's not coming back. Oof, Miles McNut really liked that talking head. He liked that Erin was doing this for other reasons. Yeah. Again, you can't go there with logic. Like, why Saber would put together this specific team of people for this specific project. Yes, it makes no sense that we need both Aaron and Kathy. Yes. Two admins. Mm-hmm. One of whom is not a permanent employee.
That's right. In fact, if they did let Kathy go since Pam has come back, they would be recouping that salary. True. Can't go there, Miles. We can't go there. Ha-ha-ha. This episode ends with the Florida group
getting into a van for the airport. Everyone's saying goodbye. Wait, wait, Kathy's on the phone. Yeah, she's talking to her friend on a bench. Yeah, she says all expenses paid. Yeah, Jim's gonna be there. Their marriage is not good. Nobody knows better than me.
Definitely, we will. It's three weeks in Tallahassee. What else is there to do? Dun, dun, dun. Guess who didn't care for this talking head? Who? Sydney and Charlotte in North Carolina. What you got Sydney wrote in and said,
the ending of this episode dot, dot, dot. Kathy. Boo! The start of this episode dot dot dot. Kathy. Boo. The start of this new Jim Kathy storyline. How did you guys Jenna especially feel about this whole quote new girl tries to steal Jim storyline. I get that Jim and Pam need conflict, but it's gross that I just don't like Kathy at all. And I feel bad because I'm sure the actress is very nice, but she had to play such an icky character. Well, Sydney, how I felt about it was that I didn't feel like we earned it, Sydney. I didn't think we earned this moment on the bench for this character of Kathy. We hadn't
seen her look at Jim, pine away for Jim, be interested in Jim. And now all of a sudden she's I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know.
I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know.
I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. And Kathy's age and in that office could be enamored with Jim. Sure. Have a type of emotional crush on him. I could see where Jim might like the attention even if he doesn't realize he does.
But none of that happens. I know, because it's all cut out. So it does seem out of absolute left field. Yeah. That's how I felt about it. Yeah. It didn't feel earned. And then as for what's going. That's how I felt about it. Yeah. It didn't feel earned. And then as for what's going to happen,
we'll get to it. We'll get to it. Well, that was special project. You guys, thanks so much for sending in your questions and comments. Thank you, Steve Burgess, for getting back to me about a few of those tidbits I was wondering about. I'm going to put on my zipper earrings.
I'm going to walk out of here feeling like fashionable mom, and we'll see you next week. We'll see you then. We hope you have a great one. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jennifer Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jirkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keeper.
Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.